[Music]
this episode and others like it are made
possible by the generous support of my
patrons on patreon
YouTube has demonetized almost all of my
recent videos so if you're able please
consider supporting this channel by
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
second thought it was a Manic Monday in
the financial markets the Dow tumbled
more than five hundred points after two
pillars of the street tumbled over the
weekend Lehman Brothers a one hundred
and fifty eight year old firm filed for
bankruptcy brought down by bad mortgage
investments Lehman which has twenty five
thousand employees will be liquidated
Merrill the country's biggest brokerage
with sixty thousand employees had been
battered by nearly fifty billion dollars
in mortgage related losses the American
people can remain confident in the
soundness and the resilience of our
financial system some people say this
this doesn't stop until the housing
housing gets bottom you think that's
true I think that's probably correct
this could be the most serious recession
in decades and that means life as most
Americans know it is about to change
holy cow things are going to be much
worse than anyone anticipates the
defaults right now are incredibly high
at unprecedented levels and there's no
evidence that the default rate is
tapering off those defaults almost
inevitably are leading to foreclosures
and homes being auctioned and home
prices continuing to fall the Great
Recession the period of economic turmoil
following the crash of 2008 is one of
those times that feels like it was just
yesterday and a million years ago at the
same time along with 9/11 and the
beginning of the Iraq war the Great
Recession remains one of the formative
events of my generations time on earth
many of us watched our parents struggle
to pay the bills countless others lost
their homes after the dust had settled
10 million Americans had been evicted or
otherwise lost their homes in the years
following the crash some were able to
find their footing again but many never
recovered from the financial ruin they
suffered 12 years ago now in the midst
of another world altering event we face
a new looming economic crisis in this
episode we're going to look at the
projections for evictions and
homelessness in the near future in the
five years after the financial crash
foreclosures and evictions displaced
over
ten million people that's more people
than the entire population of the state
of Michigan the tenth most populous
state in the country apartments suburban
homes trailers ranches nowhere was safe
for the Americans drowning in debt those
who found themselves without a home came
from all sorts of backgrounds and from
all walks of life the crisis displaced
young and old alike and those beyond
working age were simply out of luck
they wouldn't have the time to rebuild
their lost livelihoods some of these
evictions were calm others were
conducted by police officers with guns
drawn people's personal belongings being
thrown out into the streets while people
of all races were affected minority
communities were the hardest hit
according to a 2012 report by the
National Fair Housing Alliance minority
communities had been aggressively
targeted for years by loan officers
offering the worst of the worst subprime
loans often being awarded a bounty for
each minority borrower they secured the
National Fair Housing Alliance reported
that the resulting crash represented the
largest loss of wealth for these
communities in modern history as a
result of being illegally targeted for
dangerous subprime loans the white black
wealth gap ballooned to a shocking 20 to
1 ratio in retrospect the whole thing
was a disaster waiting to happen
not to mention unethical in the extreme
banks peddled toxic mortgages across the
country and when they imploded those
same banks simply evicted the borrowers
and that was that average Americans
suffered while the rich and criminal
bankers got off scot-free to make
matters worse the repossessed homes were
then snapped up by wealthy individuals
and corporations as investment
properties further reducing the already
limited supply of reasonably priced
housing one company Blackstone spent
four and a half billion dollars scooping
up over 30,000 homes after their owners
had been evicted and those homes are now
netting them a healthy profit as they're
held captive on the rental market the
Great Recession was the largest
redistribution of wealth in recent
memory and as usual the rich got richer
and everybody else got poorer but the
Great Recession is about to look like a
pleasant memory as the pandemic crisis
worsened and people began losing their
jobs at an unprecedented rate a few tiny
concessions were forced through the
government some people got a one-time
$1,200 check which covered maybe one
month of expenses and a patchwork
moratorium on evictions was established
in some states
this gave the millions of Americans
living on the razor's edge
all respite from looming disaster but as
people begin to realize that we're never
getting a second check and unemployment
benefits are set to run out just as
eviction moratoriums are lifted the
general populace is rightly terrified
according to current projections of the
110 million Americans currently living
in rental properties at least 20% of
them are at risk of eviction remember
the foreclosure crisis of 2008 displaced
10 million people over a period of years
kovat and the horrific American response
is expected to displace between 20 and
28 million people between now and
September two to three times as many
people as during the Great Recession and
in months instead of years and that's
not even taking into consideration the
people who own homes the financial crash
of 2008 ruined both renters and
homeowners and we have no reason to
assume the kovat crash will be any
different but let's talk for a moment
about the situation we face there is
currently a global pandemic ravaging the
world the US has done the worst job by
far of containing it to the point where
the very existence of the disease is
considered a political opinion and our
politicians blatantly disregard safety
regulations over 40 million people have
lost their jobs and by extension their
health care now the solution to curbing
the spread of this disease is to shelter
in place just stay home it would stand
to reason that if we want people to stay
home it would seem a rather poor
decision to forcefully remove 28 million
of them from their homes but that's
exactly what's going to happen so not
only will these people be at a greatly
heightened risk of contracting the virus
they'll also have to contend with the
mental and physical strain of becoming
homeless studies have shown that being
evicted from your home causes increased
mortality rates and respiratory distress
which is just perfect considering that
kovat is a respiratory illness but how
did this situation get so bad and is
there anything we can do to fix it the
overarching problem is the militant and
competence of American leadership
whether they truly believed we were safe
from the disease or they didn't want to
upset the all-powerful market the
outcome was the same regarding the
eviction crisis specifically the main
issue is that the federal government has
refused to issue a mandate halting all
evictions for the duration of the
pandemic any eviction moratorium
measures have been left to the state and
local levels and that has resulted in a
confusing patchwork of exemptions so
most people are unsure whether they're
living in a complex
victim as of right now 29 states offer
no state level assurances that renters
will not be evicted even in the places
that do offer assurances they are not
offered with financial assistance which
means that those people who can't pay
their rent even if they're not allowed
to be evicted right now are still going
deeper and deeper into debt and will
likely be kicked out as soon as the
eviction restrictions are lifted there's
plenty of evidence to support this
suspicion because in some states
landlords are allowed to go through the
entire eviction process court hearing
and all and are only stalled at the
execution stage that means there's a
whole mountain of eviction orders just
waiting to be pushed through the moment
they're able but wait how are these
landlords allowed to evict their tenants
without a court hearing that's part of
the problem as with just about
everything else Kovan has made court
appearances much more difficult in the
great before times when we could go out
and do things if your landlord wanted to
evict you you could appear in court and
contest it now with courts closed due to
pandemic restrictions these hearings
have to take place online let's take a
hypothetical situation here if you are
at the point of facing eviction it would
be safe to assume you've lost your job
right if someone is in such dire straits
that they're having to choose between
food and rent do you think this person
is able to spend money to keep the Wi-Fi
on to appear in digital court and that's
not even taking into consideration the
elderly people facing eviction who may
not understand how to dial into a
digital hearing or those people who are
given a broken link or whose email is
spelled incorrectly so they never get
the summons whatever the reason if the
renter fails to appear for their hearing
that's it
the judge will rule in favor of the
landlord so 28 million people can't pay
rent because they lost their jobs they
lost their health insurance because it's
tied to their employment and now they'll
be thrown into the street where they
will likely contract kovat and become
yet another vector for the disease
further worsening the situation in the
US the American response to the pandemic
has been so laughably bad that if it
were a movie no one would believe it
it's like our leaders are doing
everything in their power to make the
situation as bad as possible if we're
being honest we cannot reasonably expect
these people to suddenly figure it out
and start implementing common-sense
solutions but on the off chance that
they're watching YouTube videos to get
some ideas here are some proposals first
and foremost we need a federally
mandated moratorium on evictions and
foreclosure
no one should be at risk of losing their
home in the middle of a pandemic scrap
all the pending eviction orders and
forgive past due rent second we need a
rent and mortgage freeze for the
remainder of the pandemic if we want
people to stay at home that means they
can't work and if they can't work they
can't make rent or mortgage payments
next we need a real nationwide lockdown
I drove past a water park the other day
and there were lines everywhere shut
that down no bars no gyms no public
gatherings of any sort shut everything
down for at least two months continue
testing listen to the medical community
and the leaders of nations who beat
their outbreak finally and this is the
really critical part and the part that
will guarantee none of this will happen
the federal government needs to pay
people to stay home
people still have expenses they need to
eat they need their medications the
entire incentive to reopen the economy
is so that businesses can keep making
money and workers can get their
paychecks if we take that out of the
equation the need to reopen the country
is greatly diminished there are
proposals on the table from people like
Bernie Sanders who suggest $2,000 per
person per month for the remainder of
the pandemic for some people this will
be more than they normally make for
others it'll be less but if rent and
mortgage payments are frozen then it
should be enough money for people to
cover their essential expenses and if
you're the type of person to complain if
someone is making more than they
normally do when that 2,000 per month
would only add up to 24,000 per year you
need to re-evaluate your priorities
after the pandemic has finally passed
assuming 2020 doesn't have some other
extinction event planned for us we need
to address the housing problem there's a
decided lack of affordable housing in
America in no small part due to the
parasitic greed of the corporations who
bought up all the homes after 2008
because of this there are millions more
Americans caught in the incredibly
expensive rental market we have a long
way to go to make America the country
many Americans think it is and fair
housing practices are a key part of that
I mentioned at the beginning of this
video that this kind of content is
supported by my patrons on patreon this
type of video while very important is
something that sponsors won't touch in
order to pay the bills and keep this
channel running I rely on Adsense
revenue sponsors and donations from
generous viewers by producing explicitly
anti-capitalist content I lose out on
both sponsors and Adsense if you enjoy
the kind of videos
producing and you're able to chip in
even a dollar a month I would greatly
appreciate the support you can find my
patreon page at patreon.com slash second
thought every tear comes with discord
benefits for our new and growing discord
server you can check out my previous
episodes by clicking the links on your
screen thanks for watching and I'll see
you next week